you
okay let's try a 5-minute game on chess
calm this is the first time I'm playing
against a human in a long while
while not live-streaming so let's go
with the Karel con and we could be
having the pan of Botvinnik attack and
we are gonna have that okay I don't want
to pick up this pond right away I'd
rather do it with my knight let's get
him out and well I could grab it now
more familiar with Bishop check and
queen a4 check at this point just pick
him up right now and let's see do I
really want to try to get my bishop
outside at my eventual pawn chain when I
could be a bit risky because of these up
checks or the pressure being placed on
b7 so I'll take a more reserved approach
just go with these six Bishop e7 or
maybe not not actually Bishop e7 for a
second I was thinking knight c6 but uh I
don't know how bad Bishop b5 would be
but I think this is maybe the best place
for the bishop
since he's aiming down at that h7 square
it's nice to watch over g5 so there's
none of that Greek gift stuff going on
with the ship take Bishop takes h7 95
and let's get my night out and very
often I think this Knight actually
returns these are all who's being played
very quickly and let's see I think I
want to actually drop back with my
knight here I mean I still have to get
my Bishop out to be 7 maybe I should be
doing this but should I do this move and
then Bishop e7 or first retreat' my
knight why would I want to retreat my
knight let's see these are my two
candidate moves b6 right now or
night here could be a little bit
annoying like if Knight takes if b6
Knight takes Knight Queen takes Bishop
here and then this is a very awkward pin
I'm gonna drop this Knight back so I'm
thinking about from this point b6 Bishop
to b7 I'm working against an isolated
pawn and slight development issue I'm
not threatening to win here because of
Bishop takes h7 at the end of a couple
captures so this guy has a big lead
timewise this is this is maybe another
idea now that my Knights on f6 I could
think about night before to here and so
as a result maybe that would have been a
move to consider for white so let me
just go here right now before it's maybe
too late if you prolong that for too
long too much pressure against c6 makes
it become difficult so Bishop here right
away they don't see any reason not to do
that let's get him there so I'm
preparing some common moves our rook
here night here and they're lining up
something against this point so let's
see I think I actually want to do this
right now make sure I have this night
getting to d5 in my bishop eyeing this
directly pressure on this night as well
and I'm stopping the Queen for the time
being from going to any of those two and
I'm really seeking exchanges this could
actually be a bit annoying yeah I could
definitely be annoying threatening to
capture here and then here removing the
defender of h7 so I'm not quite sure
what I'll do if the Queen plays to one
of these two squares I think I might be
having to do g6 and I really have to
start throwing in some faster moves so
let me do this
rook see in an ideal world I want to get
my rook here some exchanges really like
to have the Queen's off the board
because of the because the pawn
structure pretty much says so working
against an isolated pawn
dynamic possibilities are on Whiteside
so I'm looking for more end game like
positions so a minute back
I really have to spent too much time
already and I have to be very cautious
of sacrifices here let me drop back and
welcome some trades here if bishop back
here maybe I I'm I was gonna say h6 but
I really don't want a week in this
structure anymore there's already a ton
of pieces aiming at that so let me fiend
cut out my bishop this looks a little
scary I'm gonna do it I'm still in this
pin so be a little bit awkward like
Knight here I want to get out of this
pin as soon as possible in fact I would
have to do just that actually that could
be very I could be very annoying night
right here Knight g4 okay I think I
actually want to do what I think I want
to trade a little bit let's do this
no I have some concern about rook takes
and then maybe I'm inviting another
piece over here okay so no not quite
and are there gonna be any sacrifices on
this square stopping me from kicking
this bishop the way I don't really like
that hmm rook to c8 and I'll give that a
shot oh no I have to I really have to do
something about this pin not here's
gonna be such a pain well you know what
I could do I could play Queen here I'll
let this rook isn't guarding the c7
square I was a bit blind here too not
realizing that my Queen now has maybe a
relatively safe square 132 to 235 hmm
like to get one more pair of minor
pieces off Queen here what do i do on
Queen here hmm very many choices
actually I don't want to come back over
and defend it and work myself into a pin
I think I'd have to go here and then
Knight g4 could be quite annoying
I think I think there's got to be
something good for white right now
okay White's not going for that why
isn't white going for that let me maybe
do this or get my Queen in a better spot
maybe oh you know what I could have
considered night here maybe I should do
that now mmm yeah let's go for this
right now there's not gonna be any
tricks on this square is there I hope
not
there might be Knight takes King takes
Queen takes pawn here yeah here we go
here we go oh yeah because of this oh
this is gonna be painful this is
definitely gonna be painful how do I
defend here I gotta go with this I'm
busted
I'm completely busted because of Bishop
here next that's not working out too
good do I have to give up this pawn pawn
push here is a disaster King to f8 maybe
oh this is gonna be very painful 39
seconds mmm
I don't see a defense I'm gonna try this
I guess Queen takes and then rook takes
here this is getting smashed ouch oh you
know what I have h2 though maybe
oh there's sniffed that one out okay I
was ready to do this and just blunder my
queen
look here yes man 14 seconds not a lot
of time in a horrible position I had a
glimmer of hope we takes h2 maybe King
here would have been better so I could
play Knight here I don't even realize
inching your way down cheeps trick
g2 I'm doing this also to have my queen
protected so that I could actually move
here and I can't even do that this is
gone
yeah because of this right here I'll
just I'm down on time oh my goodness I'm
down on time and position oh let me go
back that was ugly town that was a
successful attack where could I have
done better let's see okay I don't think
there's anything wrong with the
capturing right here I takes and then
could I've been a bit more no is this
too passive playing east six right here
hmm six Bishop e7 or maybe yeah maybe I
could have done better with my bishop
you know from I think at this point I
was thinking about Knight here here
maybe I could do one better now that my
knight is on this square why not make
use of his position and put some
pressure on the white position yeah you
know what if I could do it over I think
I would want to put some pressure on
White's position give a little bit more
direction to light for their next move
after Bishop e7 what was played Bishop
d3 so white would have to be doing
something a little bit different clearly
yeah I think Bishop b4 and then you know
it's something if Bishop here then this
square isn't as isn't defended as much
and there might be a way to put some
pressure on d4 a little bit later okay
so I don't think that this could be so
bad but I think maybe a slight
improvement Bishop d7 Bishop to b4
castles right here you know I'm not I'm
not familiar enough with this opening to
know whether or not I've maybe even lost
a move somewhere along the way like back
here I'm pretty sure is a is a common
thing to do if to just retreat that
night and make way for a knight here to
d5 sort of things sort of manoeuvers hmm
wrong b6 Bishop b7 maybe here maybe not
yes this became very troublesome it
seemed all very natural night before you
got kicked night here and now is there
way I could have avoided making this
weakness is my big question I don't know
if I'm gonna have an answer to it
Yeah right this is really the maybe it's
beyond the critical phase but we're
thinking right around here there's a way
to maybe improve if not earlier hmm I
mean I'd really like to have here's
something that I could say I'd what
would I really like to have happen I'd
like to actually have these dark square
Bishop six changed so that when I do do
this move he's not around to maybe take
advantage of them maybe I don't know
what just happened there that was weird
what a finishing I thought there so that
the dark square bishop wouldn't be
around to maybe harass me on the dark
squares and maybe I could rely upon this
f6 square a bit better for the defense
of my own King hmm
so oh that wasn't the move I'm not even
sure what just happened there it's not
me let me try to reload this real quick
actually okay I just had to quickly
reload it I'm not sure what just
happened there when that pawn kind of
made a weird capture on f6 like that so
I just quickly reloaded the PGN so I
don't know where exactly I went wrong so
it's a very uncomfortable feeling I know
I'm I'm well aware of this pressure
against h7 and I didn't do well at all
for sure with trying to get exchanges
and the only exchange I got wore a pair
of Knights and that really didn't help
me out so much this there were what
one two three four attacking pieces no
actually five nearly every piece except
for this rook right here on c1
is doing something against my king so
this was a very nice sacrifice again
state f7 maybe maybe even here come to
think of it is there something else I
could be doing instead of Bishop to g7
here this Queen swinging over that's
very neat and you know what come to
think of it earlier I was talking about
you know the cool placing itself to c2
or d3 so looking back at this game we
could maybe even see a difference in a
better meaning behind Queen to d3 in
that she has this opportunity to shift
along the third-ranked
not just being maybe more
one-dimensional so if she's on c3 we can
or one-directional
she's not just focused on the diagonal
but by pivoting on d3 you're threatening
that h7 and you're also threatening to
come over to this age 3 square and put
pressure on this structure right here
ties in well with the rook and the night
when it comes to this f7 and ecig
structure with the Queen right here
bearing down on e6 there's a very nice
break through right here I took this was
I guess well it's not is it available
even at this point right here to capture
oh you know what that capture card as
soon as my knight that's another maybe a
quick instructive point as soon as my
knight left that post on f6 it's just
game over I think that this is just a
correct and good sacrifice in every
which way every single one of whites
pieces working and I just got crushed
yeah and I takes f7 King takes and I'm
not seeing a defense Knight here is met
with Bishop here at the very least and
I'm not that seeing a way to defend that
I was trying to do something against the
King but it was just all one move
threats like right here I was thinking
about what oh my queen is unprotected so
I didn't do this thinking that white was
gonna over look at me and
but I was just trying to have my queen
protected so I think I could do this
move right here but this is just a
killer move d5 and I just down on time
and position just gone this is an
important sacrifice to be aware of
certainly in the on the white side and
black side just out of this opening
panic Botvinnik attack sacrifices on f7
these are all very common moves on the
white side and I definitely didn't do
well with it
okay that's all for this video as always
I hope you got something out of it take
care bye
you